richtig fand
und jetzt macht
falsch macht der film was er machen muss
was er falsch machen muss er ist das
mittelstück von irgendeiner geschichte
das heißt er drängt das ziemlich
zusammen ist sozusagen ein relativ enger
handlungs zeitraum es passiert kurz nach
dem letzten es ist eine brücke und es
ist sozusagen so eine art scharnier
geschichte von einer brücke dieses mal
zusammengedrückt wird wie möglich das
heißt wahrscheinlich werden wir mehr
zeit vergehen sehen spüren hören bis zum
nächsten film und das ist halt falsch in
dem sinne also sozusagen mich
befriedigend ist weil man in wien ende
will es kann logischerweise keines geben
ich habe die gesamte macht nur einmal
zuvor gesehen damals hat es mich nicht
genug licht
[Musik]
doch jetzt schon inhaltlich werde ich
natürlich den satan tun irgendein
spoiler hier auspacken und erzählen was
passiert interessant ist aber dass die
art fragen auf die es hier antworten
gibt eine andere art fragen ist als das
früher bei star wars der fall war die
fragen früher hatten viel zu tun mit
dieser hippie watt birnen religionen die
die jedi-ritter da vertreten hat in die
3 also irgendwie fühle es dann für ist
es schon fühlen und so die ist nicht
mehr so wichtig wie man dachte die
blutsbande geschichte ist nicht mehr so
wichtig wie man dachte also die
brüderchen und schwesterchen und werden
jetzt mit wem und ist den raps wirklich
der illegitime sohn von jock ewing in
der last das steht nicht so im
mittelpunkt wie man vielleicht gedacht
hätte und die vorstellung von krieg ist
eine andere bis jetzt war krieg weil es
damals eigentlich immer der zweite
weltkrieg nämlich die guten gegen die
absolut bösen also die mit den uniformen
und den totenköpfen und sowas
ist eine figur sagt an einer stelle
unser sieg wird nicht sein oder hängt
damit zusammen dass wir das bekämpfen
was wir hassen sondern dass wir das
retten das belieben also auch da
sozusagen ein neuer outlook in star wars
universum und schließlich die
vorstellung von was sind eigentlich
herrscher was ist eigentlich macht was
ist eigentlich unterdrückung ausgrenzung
und so weiter dies auch ein bisschen
raffinierter als früher insofern es
früher so war das einfach so eine art ss
gestapo einfach mal so geherrscht hat
also das was normalerweise mittel von
herrschaft ist weil hier schon der ganze
zweck und hier kriegen wir zumindest mal
ein paar profiteure zu sehen sein was
wir sollten von klassen die gesellschaft
zerfällt oder nicht zerfällt
richtig macht der film vor allen dingen
eins erklärt zurück sozusagen zu einem
taktilen
haptischen sinnlichen star wars gefühl
dass durch diese überbetonung von
computer quatsch lukas hat das ja
eingeführt die den computer trickfilmen
in den film sozusagen und hier ist es
wieder so dass die außerirdischen
teilweise er nach puppen aussehen als
nach digitalem zeug was sozusagen den
charme gerade der klassischen drei filme
gemacht hat dass es da diese puppen gab
das ist ein großer vorteil weil die welt
dadurch anders riecht schmeckt sich
anfühlt und sozusagen suggestiver ist
auf eine gute art meine
lieblingsgeschichte dazu ist immer noch
das kleine mädchen das bei mir in der
schlange mal war das zu seinem vater
sagte papa ist das 3d oder ist das ein
film dieses hier ist empfehlen
ein rotor ein regisseur einen sozusagen
filmkünstler kann sich da natürlich
nicht wirklich ausleben weil die
franchise einen ziemlich bindet aber
ryan johnson denen sie dann gefunden
haben ist jemand der mit genre durchaus
spielen kann und der das auf eine art
tut die gleichzeitig weiß dass etwas zu
verbiegen interessanter und auch
lustiger sein kann als etwas zu
zerbrechen was als konventionen
daherkommt er hat zwei filme gemacht
briggs war so sein gesellenstück das ist
so eine art neuer krimi teil aber auf
eine art die ein bisschen anders ist und
dann super das war ein zeitreise film
der auch ein bisschen anders ist und
dieser star wars films auch ein bisschen
anders also war eine etwas andere
regisseure
lass die vergangenheit sterben
sagte sie
wenn es sein muss
nur so kannst du werden wozu du warst
der beste
interessant daran ist tatsächlich wie
viele flanken von diesem schiff man im
laufe der jahre austauschen konnte und
es trotzdem immer noch dasselbe schiff
und ich glaube das ist deswegen dasselbe
schiff weil wir das selber da sozusagen
erkennen wollen den schlächter science
fiction heißt ja manchmal die außerdem
kommen aus dem sternbild des schützen es
gibt natürlich gar kein sternbild des
schützen weil das sind irgendwelche
sterne die verbinden nur wir hier zum
sternbild des schützen und dieses wir
verbinden ist das wird sozusagen den
fans hier zugemutet den alten wie den
neuen und das gelingt aber ganz gut also
ich kann ihn schützen erkennen viele
andere die den film gesehen haben können
das auch
ich brauche jemanden der
mir meinen platz in allem zeigt
[Musik]